President Trump is at Camp David this
morning after postponing a scheduled
trip to Poland mr. Trump said Friday
with hurricane Dorian barreling toward
the southern coast he was needed here in
the US Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula good morning good morning Dana the
president will be joined at Camp David
by officials from FEMA and they'll
continue to monitor the storm the
president was asked if he's concerned
about his mar-a-lago resort which is
directly in the path of this hurricane
but he said he's not thinking about that
he said what he's thinking about is the
state of Florida ahead of a storm he
warns could be devastating hurricane is
roaring and it could be a big one
president Trump left Friday evening for
Camp David where he will continue to
monitor Hurricane Dorian I'm going to
Camp David we have a lot of experts with
us we have a lot of the FEMA people that
are coming up but we're really very
importantly coming back mr. Trump is
coming back Sunday before the storm
makes landfall for a meeting at FEMA
headquarters that will be about the time
that we'll know where everything's going
a lot of decisions will be made that'll
be a little bit less than a day before
it hits the president is also dealing
with storms inside the White House after
the departure of his longtime personal
assistant and director of Oval Office
operations
Madeleine Western out I really think she
had a bad night sources tell CBS News
that Westar hal was drinking at an
off-the-record dinner in New Jersey
during the president's August vacation
and disclosed private details about the
president's family I think it was
unfortunate she said she was drinking
but still you don't say things like she
said which were just a little bit
hurtful to some people and then there
were the political storms brewing this
week those were very serious charges mr.
Trump answered questions for the first
time about the Inspector General's new
report on former FBI director James
Comey he was asked Friday if he was
disappointed his Attorney General
William bar was not prosecuting the
former FBI chief they have total
confidence in Bill Bart to do the right
thing I think of anything they showed
how fair he is but certainly those were
very soon
charges but let's see what happened the
president says this weekend he will also
continue trade talks with China and this
comes ahead of another round of tariffs
on Chinese goods scheduled to go into
effect on Sunday Jeff Paul thank you
very much